hot breath next one here from wayne
flake jr
are there any writing techniques that
you have found most helpful
um just to write every day you know i
like to free write
in the morning just get some ideas out
um i
i usually call my writing style more
more fishing than hunting
you know i'm not necessarily like oh
this is what we're doing i kind of like
sit and i let things come to me and then
um so it's very
um slow in that way but
i think one of my favorite techniques
when i don't have anything like when i'm
like oh i need to just come up with a
topic
is i'll take a grid and will just write
um love hate fear and then i will
go through what do i love right now what
do i hate right now what do i fear right
now
and i know if i can come up with
something that pulls those emotions out
of me then those are probably subjects i
should write about and talk about on
stage
so you'll list out some things under
love hate fear and then you may pick one
and start free writing about it is that
kind of the distillation
yes exactly and then from freewriting
you then have whittled that down into
maybe a few phrases or ideas that then
you take to the stage or do you get even
more specific on the word for word
no yeah once i have this idea you know
once i have the idea then i
put it on stage and i always say
that like i'll know i'll know the idea
the audience will tell me what the joke
is
you know when they laugh then the joke
is stopped
right right right but is that a skill
that
you worked into because a lot of the
times younger comics are like
i'll just go up there and figure it out
because this professional comic of 30
years said to
that's what he does like is it something
you worked into or were you always
yeah yeah yeah okay something you just
do off the top i definitely
think you should have some years of
experience first um i mean but i think
that's
how like the you know with any
experience any job
you just feel more comfortable when i
first started i had to write full ass
scripts
you know like they were word for word
what i was going to say but that made me
a
bad performer because i you know i
wasn't even
thinking about laughs i wasn't even
thinking about like oh i'm gonna have to
stop here
you know i just had a monologue
basically
and then i stopped writing like that and
then i would just start writing kind of
like a grocery list where it would just
be like
oh this is the subject this is the
subject this is the subject
um i'm gonna talk about it and i might
have a punch line in mind or i might
have
a setup in mind but i usually didn't
it would you know talk it out and then
just you know see if sometimes bomb but
sometimes people would laugh and i'd go
oh okay
that's how i should say it next time